isis have you heard about these people
you might know them as isil or isis or
is or
ass or whatever they just released a
little video
kind of threatening president obama it
just came out today let's take a look
[Music]
combat troops will not be returning to
fight in iraq
okay so that is not a joke that they
released that
and uh flames of war has kind of a movie
trailer feel i think they might have
done that on the iphone 6 with that
slow motion stuff i get so tired of
having to wait for the war to start
through all the trailers
it's the trailer is that game yeah oh
man uh wait
so first let's since this one's a sequel
that's right
how many sequels this is part three part
three yeah the the
and that's supposed to be the the
stronger one yeah um
wait first could we just talk about the
production values i mean these guys are
really like this isn't just little
camera like this is like a real
slick operation at this point well sort
of i mean
they have final cut pro that's not that
big of a deal at this point
you know you can bootleg that software
at this point yeah
are you impressed by the production
value
i've been in things made cheaper than
that
but uh
[Laughter]
i i've tried to buy all the copies yeah
uh no i'm in one right now buddy
yeah right i i think that uh
this is it's an odd thing
when you know what capabilities will be
coming your way
it just seems like that drunk you see in
the video footage dancing in the highway
you know like just dancing in front of
cars and then a car hits them
you know it's kind of like they're
standing waiting to get hit
it it just dazzles me that they could be
so clever and so stupid all at the same
time
so are they are they kind of goat us
into doing more like what's the
propaganda award
and they're clearly trying to bring us
into into a fight it's
begging for it and it's it's and we are
stupid enough to take the bait and
what they basically said when when you
start beheading people on
on camera what you're essentially saying
is we are going to
uh to to fight in a war as
inefficiently as is humanly possible
send over your guys one at a time
and we will take care of them with this
kitchen knife and we're going
why we have to take that challenge it's
a martial arts precept
anyone whether it is a human or a nation
becomes predictable when they are angry
or afraid
[Music]
cosine you're co-signing that on that
when you're angry
you're showing it's like you're playing
poker with the hand facing outward
yeah they show an attack shows all your
weaknesses all at once
sun tzu yeah art of war and uh
i i think they're doing it in an order
that's so clumsy it's so school play
look with our cool g.i joe action
outfits where we're clearly
we all look so similar you can spot us
with a satellite to see when we're
moving anywhere you can look at what
we're dressed like
yeah we've made it so easy for you to
hit us how can you not do it
so how much should we pay attention to
their propaganda because even when we're
discussing what topics we should do on
the show we're going to do we're going
to do something about beheading in a
second a couple other isis things
i'm constantly debating are we i think
it's important to talk about so because
as americans we need to know what's
going on in the world but on the other
hand i don't want to strengthen
the fear side and you know this because
we do there is definitely a feeling in
america of running up to war right now
we can really feel that right
so how much do you think we actually
have to talk about it uh
without making it bigger than it
actually is either one
talking about it is one thing but
responding to it in a certain way like
dylan was saying
is the other it's very important that if
i
establish my it's like what happened in
ferguson your opponent wanted a riot
what do you give them well not a riot
exactly don't give them what they want
and then they look stupid standing there
in star wars outfits
uh if you gave them a riot suddenly
they're validated for wearing star wars
office see
we needed them obviously we have to have
five more years of funding for this
people are rioting you shouldn't
necessarily have peep soldiers pointing
uh machine guns at them
there's no riot right i go the other way
if there are soldiers wandering around
the streets with machine guns
don't give them the riot they're looking
for i think that's what rick is saying
yeah i'm saying when
you're baiting me into a riot no ryan no
right why because you want it that's why
yeah it's because it's your wish i
forbid you the thing your objective is i
forbid you that
and it worked and that's the tactic and
the same thing
could work here as if they're begging us
into a fight if anything
seems like a couple of seal teams could
take care of this entire group
while they're sleeping right so
obviously there is nothing
there is nothing we can gain by going
into this war
there's an emotional satisfaction of
throwing a punch and maybe breaking your
knuckles
but there is nothing to be gained from
going into this war there are perhaps
perhaps 30 000 isis fighters um
or as clinton i think would have said it
depends on what your definition of isis
but there are maybe 30 000 of them and
we let's say we managed to kill all 30
000 of them
right because in in the bizarre prospect
that a war is the thing to do
that's what you're trying to do is kill
all the other guys right so if we
kill all 30 000 of them then there are
60
000 children and brothers and so on who
now know
that the u.s came and killed our guys
right with their bombs over whatever the
hell it is we're doing it over
outrage we're doing it over outrage at
this point yeah emotional button pushing
is going on here can we all admit that's
happening yeah well absolutely that's
why
i mean the media is running this thing